[Música]
[Aplausos]
qué es inspirar
inspirar es jalar aire hacia los
pulmones
ya los estoy inspirando
inspirar escalar lo que alguien más de
edad es llenar tus pulmones de energía
de aliento de emoción es tomar aire para
aventarse al vacío con seguridad
durante mi vida he tenido muchos
momentos de inspiración que me ayudaron
a cambiar mi óptica de las cosas y que
me sacaron de mi zona de confort
a los 14 años me corrieron de la escuela
por irresponsable
a los 16
me puse a trabajar para comprarme cosas
y no pedir dinero a mis padres
a los 20 me casé porque apareció el
hombre ideal
pero a los 31 me divorcié porque era
mejor estar sola sola que sola
acompañada
a los 37 nace mi hijo mi máxima
inspiración
a los 43 conozco a mi cómplice y
compañero de vida
a los 53
se crea una empresa de consultoría y
capacitación junto con unas amigas
y a los 58 años estoy aquí tratando de
inspirarlos
cuando me enfrente a mis padres a los 14
años por mi falta de responsabilidad me
di cuenta de la importancia de mis actos
estaba yo dejando una escuela en la que
había pasado momentos maravillosos y
además había logrado hacer muy buenos
amigos
en ese momento
tenía yo que presentar un examen
extraordinario y extemporáneo si no lo
pasaba
perdí a un año o me escribirían en una
escuela que no me gustaba nada
con la ayuda de mi madre me moví y pude
resolver
a los 16 años me metí a trabajar
vendiendo árboles de navidad en 15 días
pude ganar lo equivalente hoy a 30 mil
pesos
la verdad me gustó muchísimo saber que
podía ganar mi dinero y gastarlo en lo
que yo quisiera y eso me motivó a seguir
trabajando hasta la fecha
posteriormente entré a un trabajo ya
formal y estaba yo emocionadísima me
sentía importantísima
pero me topé con un hombre que me hizo
la vida imposible
el el menosprecio mi falta de
experiencia todo el tiempo
en lo que quería era una persona que le
hiciera su trabajo porque a él no le
gustaba mucho trabajar
fue a tal grado que yo mi desesperación
que yo fui con el director del área y le
pedí que por favor me cambiara si a otro
lado y él me dio mi primera lección
diciéndome si tú logras manejar a este
compadre vas a manejar a todos los
compadres que se te presenten en tu vida
porque con padres como este hay en todos
lados
la verdad salí de su oficina muy
entusiasmada no porque yo iba a manejar
a este compadre
pero la emoción me duró poco porque el
compadre salió más rápido de lo que me
imaginé de mi empresa
la felicidad me duró también poco
porque como diría
ralph waldo un filósofo del siglo 19 me
enfrenté a mi hermoso enemigo un hombre
que me retaba todo el tiempo me
provocaba me re marcaba mis mis errores
incluso hasta con plumón rojo y yo tenía
que repetir todo el trabajo porque en
aquella época no habían las computadoras
que hay hoy en día y lo tenía yo que
hacer a máquina
yo no sé si él sabía pero yo muchas
veces me llegué a meter al baño a llorar
y estaba enojada y lloraba conmigo misma
por no haberme dado cuenta en este
momento de mis errores
él fue un hombre que me enseñó a
trabajar
me hizo conocer mi trabajo como nadie
todos los proyectos que yo llevaba me
hizo realmente saber de qué se trataban
y eso me hizo que yo tuviera muchísima
seguridad él fue mi gran mentor y ahora
uno de mis mejores amigos
en ese momento mi oficina daba a un
pasillo que daba a la oficina del
director general yo todos los días veía
como hombres trajeados con portafolios
entraban a las salas de juntas y se
tardaban ahí a la mejor una hora dos
horas oa veces mucho más y yo me
preguntaba qué resuelve en esta gente
allá adentro pero de qué platican se
paran al baño toman un café de qué se
habla y adentro
algún día ahí voy a estar
y como es irónica la vida hoy después de
muchos años el mayor tiempo que yo paso
en mi oficina es en una sala de juntas
y que creen ni resuelvo nada
platico de todo menos de lo que debo y
en ocasiones es aburridísimo
[Aplausos]
en mi vida profesional y va en ascenso
pero mi matrimonio no
la desigualdad en la ambición la
desigualdad laboral
hizo que hiciéramos vidas paralelas y
eso jugó en nuestra contra hasta llegar
a la separación
yo tenía en aquel momento 35 mil pesos
mi coche y mi ropa
la vida me aventaba nuevamente empezar
de nuevo sería yo 100%
responsable de mis objetivos y de lo que
pasará a futuro
a los 37 años
seguía yo trabajando muchísimo pero era
un momento clave en mi vida llegó la
maternidad lo que para muchas mujeres
significa dejar de trabajar yo no tuve
opción estaba en ese momento sola
sin embargo
todo salió muy bien
en ese momento
aparte yo me había acabado de cambiar de
trabajo
entonces tuve que regresar exactamente a
los 40 días de incapacidad
no habían horarios flexibles no había
trabajo en casa así es que yo acababa
completamente agotada tuve que pedir
ayuda confiar en mi nuevo equipo de
trabajo y además generar una red de
apoyo en mi casa
pero eso no me libró del sentimiento de
culpabilidad de haber dejado a mi hijo
solo tan pequeño
cosa que me dolió muchísimo
pero bueno pasa
[Aplausos]
pero la motivación era tan grande de
sacarlo adelante el apoyo de mi familia
incondicional
y es un trabajo que me gustaba hizo que
yo lograra un balance
ya cuando estaba más o menos ubicada en
este contexto
conozco a mi cómplice ya mi compañero de
vida
en ese momento
hijo casa trabajo y ahora una nueva
familia
y aquí aplique el refrán que dice el que
quiere la col quiere todo lo de
alrededor
y la verdad fue muy cierto nos costó
trabajo un poco la adaptación pero lo
pudimos lograr
yo en ese momento que estaba tratando de
acoplarse en ti a que mi vida era un
caos
y además trabajaba yo en ese momento en
un ambiente super masculino
y llegué a escuchar frases como vieja
loca
mal querida y eso me ardía la sangre
y seguían existiendo los famosos clubes
de toby en donde las mujeres no podíamos
pertenecer donde los códigos de conducta
hacían mucho más difícil
nuestra cabida y la verdad eso fue muy
difícil teníamos que trabajar doble yo
tuve que trabajar doble en mantener mis
puntos de vista en que me respetaran mis
padres y en poner los límites en una
ocasión uno de ellos me habló un día
furioso porque no lo había tomado yo en
cuenta para una decisión
me habló tan enojado que estaba gritando
en el teléfono y le dije oh me dejas de
gritar o te voy a colgar
no me hizo caso y le colgué me volvió a
marcar y le volvía a colgar le volvía a
marcar y me volvió a colgar y así no sé
cuántas veces yo me pregunto yo me
pregunto
quién es el viejo loco y el mal querido
el trabajo te tiene que gustar pero no
lo quieras tanto porque si no te lleva a
esos extremos
a mis 53 años yo seguía llena de energía
y yo quería junto con unas amigas
maravillosas
devolverle algo a la sociedad algo a la
vida de lo que nos había dado y es
cuando se crea la empresa de consultoría
y capacitación para apoyar a las mujeres
a que sigan creciendo en sus puestos a
que se avienten a tomar decisiones a que
sean dueñas de sus sueños a que se
quieran a que se mantengan sus valores a
que la decisión la ponga en medio de su
vida
y que la comuniquen a su familia
ha sido una maravillosa experiencia
a mis 58 años
tengo muchísimos planes tengo ganas de
seguir aprendiendo tengo ganas de seguir
avanzando
amo a mi familia
amo a mis amigos
amo a mis compañeros de trabajo quiero
al trabajo pero no lo amo
la verdad amo a mi diario amanecer
he sido el hermoso enemigo de algunos
cuantos lo sé motivado los he provocado
los he tratado de guiar con la consigna
de que sigan creciendo y verme aquí
ahora yo con el reto de continuar
inspirando a quien más me inspira muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]